in the closing years of the central to
that Japan was consumed by perpetual
conflict
in this fight between the large warrior
and the swordsman note the crest on the
helmet of the smaller warrior it's
almost identical to the one that the
escena clans commander wears so this
swordsman is either that same main
antagonist of sukira shadows die twice
who goes on to cut off our arm or more
likely it's the grandfather of the
commander who is known as the legendary
escena ition he was a sword Saint who
rested this country from its former
owners and who went on this big campaign
to embed the escena clan within this
country if so this battle that we're
seeing here could be the battle that
started at all in the aftermath of the
fight our young cicchitto kneels on the
battlefield and he's unaware or uncaring
that he's being approached by another
warrior
[Music]
what's the matter stray nothing left to
lose
considering he already has two katanas
on his back and he's being called astray
he may either be looting the battlefield
or perhaps he's wishing that he was
stronger because it's possible that he
has indeed lost everything well would
you look at that will you join me
starving wolf the grizzled warrior who
is covered in this sash of feathers is
almost certainly the owl a man who took
cicchitto under his wing and raised him
to become the wolf we know this because
in another trailer one of the owls old
acquaintances named Lady butterfly calls
us his brat and as sukira grabs the owl
sword he displays his willingness to
start anew he is later we realized how
the grown-up wolf got that scar that day
I pulled you from the battlefield I had
no idea what you look
with this trailer you can already see
the tragedy unfolding we get this
chilling insight into why a shinobi
feels so driven to recover the prince
after we lose him it's because the owl
rescued sukira from the battlefield and
raised him as a sort of foster father
and sukira the wolf us we were not able
to be that same man to the foster child
we lost in the coming 24 hours I'm going
to be releasing another video called the
prosthetic art challenge and if you're
an artist if you know an artist or hell
if you feel like commissioning an artist
for this please get involved or spread
the word the goal put simply is to
design a prosthetic arm weapon that we
haven't seen before for prizes I'm
putting up fifteen hundred dollars of my
own money for the top ten entrants we've
got Humble Bundle keys for the
runners-up and there's a potential
mystery prize if you send in your
submission within two weeks the goal is
to give pretty much every serious
entrant a prize and because I'm going to
be showing off the winners and their
portfolio in another video hey this
could be a cool opportunity if you're an
artist looking to make a name for
yourself and I know everyone in the
comments will appreciate the hell out of
any art you make for us so check out the
video in the description for more
details on how to enter I'll be giving
you guys an art template that you can
draw on and a lot more details so check
it out and I hope to see you there